there was so much hype leading up to the
Avengers in-game trailer that we
officially got today I've been reading
all the comments and I really do
appreciate everybody support I really
appreciate everybody who has supported
me since the start of this channel and
over these last few weeks with the
trailer watch and the Russo brothers Q&A
you really have no idea how much it
means to me to read all of these
thoughtful comments where you guys tell
me how much you enjoy my channel this
last week with all the excitement it
definitely hasn't been a one-man show
I've had help from sources that allow me
to get you all the information that you
enjoy so much that being said I thought
it would be something really special to
have one of these sources come on my
channel and give you his perspective on
the new trailer he's a film editor and
he works directly with IMAX he's in the
industry with Marvel and all other types
of film companies he helped me keep you
all up to date with the wrister brothers
QA and his Twitter handle is at I'm a
film editor it's awesome to have him
here his name's Vaughn why don't you
introduce yourself oh absolutely it's
great to be here cosmyk I've been a fan
for a long time and I want to thank you
guys for following me on Twitter and
Instagram and keeping up to date with my
adventures at the Avengers infinity war
Q&A with the Russo brothers it was so
great to meet them a geek out with them
and talk about how Marvel got me into
film editing it was great to show you
guys photos and pictures and keep you up
to date with cosmic about everything
that happened that was such a fun day
and great to meet all you guys on
Twitter yeah it was great working with
you on that and I'm glad you're here so
let's just dive right into this trailer
so it starts off with Tony Stark with a
very intense scene it's Tony recording a
message to pepper in case she finds it
because it was really no way to get it
to her we know that he lost
communication with pepper and his AI
Friday as he was leaving earth he just
lost the Thanos and now he's dying
because he's ran out of food and water
and he's about to run out of air and it
just kind of seems like he's given up
yeah well I mean what a great way to
open the trailer I mean I was discussing
it with a lot of people when we were
predicting about what this trailers
gonna be like and I said you have to
show the cost of the decimation as they
call it or the snap because you have to
show that there was consequence to what
happened there was consequence to our
heroes lose
and now they're just like us at the end
of infinity war while the credits were
rolling they're feeling the impact too I
mean not only has Tony presumably in his
mind lost pepper forever because he's
you know stranded in space on the Milano
he also lost Peter Parker the kid that
he was mentoring and promised that he
would never let anything happen to so
it's a very depressing and somber
opening to the trailer but I always said
you had to open it this way so you can
so show the cost of the snap and what
that did to our characters and not only
could Tony not stop danos from
performing the snap and wiping out half
of the universe but now he's stranded in
space and he's about to die and they did
a really great job creating a ominous
vibe with the music and the visual
effects of this teaser yeah what a great
color palette to open the scene on
because this shows the vastness of the
cosmos and how alone Tony must feel
being one human being in the vastness of
space so I really love what the Russo
brothers chose for this color palette
shows how lonely an ominous it must feel
very eerie to be in that position
absolutely and I feel like he doesn't
only just feel this hopelessness because
he's about to die but he also feels this
extreme weight knowing that he couldn't
save the people that he loved like you
mentioned Spider Man yeah absolutely and
especially how we talked about how Tony
Stark enters ebony ma ship and pepper
cuts off due to the connection that they
lose
I always predicted that she was gonna
tell him that she was pregnant and maybe
she is pregnant maybe she just we didn't
want to reveal it to him I I definitely
think that Tony Stark will have a kid in
this movie and I feel like that's there
was a specific reason why the pepper off
not just due to the connection but I
think she was gonna see something that
was vastly important that's gonna tie
back into this and Tony's gonna have and
feel even more guilt for having left in
the first place and he's stranded in
space so he doesn't even know if peppers
alive right now or if she was victim to
the snap that makes his already hopeless
message that much more hopeless and that
sort of sets the scene for the rest of
the trailer and then we move on to the
Marvel Studios logo too soon Marvel the
logos bring us back to the memory
of sitting through those credits and
what we just experienced infinity war
yeah I think as Marvel intended that
just hit a lot of people right in the
fields and then we transitioned into the
ranch that we sought and I was resting
at at the end of infinity war and this
ties right back into that quote he has
with dr. strange when he says I finally
rest and watched the Sun Rise on the
grateful universe and he did and he
definitely see that you see his
destroyed gauntlet and he's rushing the
flowers and plants as he's walking by
and it seems like because all of his
armor is on the Scarecrow it seems like
if you look closely he's wearing new
material as clothes and it definitely
looks like or they're actually alluding
to farmer Thanos yeah it definitely
looks like it's farmer Thanos right from
the Infinity Gauntlet saga a comic book
and I love them they pay tribute to the
comics and take things from the comics
and put them in the movies so then we go
to this next scene where we have the
Avengers are all together Thor's back
with the Avengers because he came down
in Wakanda and they're all together and
they're all just defeated Black Widow
was talking about how Thanos did exactly
what he said he was going to do and they
couldn't stop him we can see Steve
Rogers crying and then we see banner
looking at the heroes that are missing
they say missing because they don't know
if these heroes are victims of the snap
or not they don't know where Scott Lang
or Peter Parker is because they haven't
really been involved since the events of
Civil War so they don't know if they're
alive or they're dusted and of course we
know that Scott Lang is alive and Peter
Parker is dust they don't know if Sheree
is dust or alive right now which is kind
of weird because they were in what Conda
so maybe she's dust even though the
Russo brothers said she wasn't but also
Hawkeye they don't know where he is he
wasn't involved in the events of
infinity war either yeah because
everybody was discussing about where
Hawkeye was in the vengers infinity war
and in this movie we're gonna find out
why he was absent so in this scene it
definitely looks like Black Widow has
tracked me down in Japan and we've heard
from previous rumors and leaks that
there are going to be scenes that
showcase the Yakuza who are basically
gangsters and ninjas
Japan and it seems like from this
trailer that Hawkeye aka Ronan has
hunted some of them down and it seems
like the Yakuza leader who's laying dead
in front of Ronan is no other than he
Rochus nada who was cast in an
unspecified role in Avengers endgame but
now it seems like from this trailer we
can tell that he's actually playing the
Yakuza cult leader and it seems like the
rumors in the leaked set photos of ronan
on set of Avengers endgame came out to
be true because his outfits new he has a
new style of bow and arrow and he has
the short haircut that we saw from the
set photos so he looks really awesome
yeah he does look really awesome and I
love the swords Steve Rogers says they
lost a part of themselves and that's
exactly why Clint ditched the Hawkeye
persona and became Ronin because he most
likely lost his family to the snap which
made him lose a part of himself and then
we cut to a moment with Steve and
Natasha and it seems like Captain
America is wearing the original suit
that he wore in the opening fight scenes
of Captain America the Winter Soldier
this is really awesome because this was
actually one of my favorite Captain
America suits so if the rumors and
speculations about the time-travel plot
of Avengers endgame are to be true it
seems like Captain America is wearing
his old SHIELD agent suit from Captain
America the Winter Soldier now I'm
wondering if you found the shield agent
suit in a Quinjet or an abandoned SHIELD
agent facility or this isn't the time
travel and he went back in time and now
he's sporting his old suit and I also
find it interesting that while he's
talking he's looking at a picture of
Peggy I'm wondering if this is sort of a
note to time travel as well or maybe
he's just looking at it because he
misses her and he realizes that this
could be the end very soon and you can
tell that whatever plan they have is a
very desperate attempt by them and you
can tell by what black widow says to
Steve she says this is gonna work and he
replies I know it is cuz I don't know
what I'm gonna do if it doesn't I find
that wine really interesting too because
there's a lot of speculation that cap is
not gonna survive avengers endgame and
we all speculated that cap is gonna die
for a long time and I still believe that
I think this line kind of foreshadows
that because cap has lost everything
back from the 40s Bucky was brainwashed
he's barely himself and the world just
lost 50% of his population so he's seen
a lot of
stress in his life and I feel like what
he means here is if they lose again he
doesn't know how he's gonna live with
himself or if he wants to live at all
and then we have finally the title
Avengers endgame what the Russo brothers
said that it wasn't gonna be ended up
being the title
yeah that's an awesome title I mean it's
very straight forward and I said this at
the IMAX premiere for Avengers infinity
war when Doctor Strange says we're in
the endgame now I said that's going to
be the title among everybody else that
predicted that and we were right yeah
that's awesome but it's just really
funny how the Russo brothers trolled us
like that and then we have the final
scene with ant-man in which some people
might be a little bit surprised because
I don't know if I expected to see
ant-man in the teaser trailer because
last time we saw him he was stranded
inside of the quantum realm yeah it
might be shocking for some people but I
actually predicted that he would be in
this trailer because I think it's
important to show that he got out and as
most of us know he was gonna get out
because we saw the leaked set photos of
him walking around in his actual suit
interacting with past Steve and current
Tony so it's gonna be very interesting
to see how that goes down yeah it's
definitely gonna be really interesting
like you said we've had those leaks for
a while we know that they go back in
time I'm really interested to see how
ant-man gets out of the quantum realm
but I think we're going to have to wait
till the movie comes out to find that
out and speaking of they changed the
date it was originally scheduled for May
3rd I believe and they changed it to
April 26th and that was no surprise to
me because the Russo brothers actually
said that the movie in production was
very ahead of schedule so I'm glad this
happened he kind of anticipated it which
is awesome I'm glad they moved it up
even though it's just a week sooner but
we anticipated the trailer so much and
what an awesome teaser it was I mean I
put on my Twitter that was one of the
best cut teaser trailers I've ever seen
I mean it gave us the mood
give us the tension that the characters
are going through and the cost of what
the snap did in Avengers infinity war
and I cannot wait to go to my IMAX
theater to experience this in the IMAX
aspect ratio as most of you know
Avengers infinity war and Avengers 4
were shot completely using IMAX cameras
which is a milestone for that format as
if you've been following me on Twitter
for a while you know how much I'm ex
means to me so I cannot wait to go and
experience the trailer in this way and
if you guys remember I actually put up a
tweet that said I will be going to my
IMAX theater and sharing screen shots of
the IMAX expert ratio for you all so we
can see if we can see anything in the
larger frame and just experience it in
IMAX overall which would be awesome
experiencing the trailer in IMX format
that would just be insane and I'm sure
you'll let us know if you find anything
else in the imax format that we didn't
see in the trailer that we saw on
YouTube and of course if you did I will
be sure to report it to everybody
yeah that sounds fantastic and thanks
cosmic for having me on I mean this was
a long time coming we've teased to our
followers that we were going to do this
trailer breakdown and it was awesome and
you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at i'm a film editor you can
keep up to date with my news my film
projects anything imax related anything
film related for all you film geeks out
there so thanks for having me on cosmic
Wonder this was awesome well thanks for
coming on Vaughan I loved having you on
my channel and thanks for providing info
to me so I can keep everybody up to date
during this last week it was crazy but
the trailer finally came and it was
awesome and again I just want to thank
everybody for all the support that
you've given me since the start of my
channel all the way up until now it
means the world to me
and I just can't thank you all enough
don't forget about to giveaway i'm doing
i'm giving away a life-size Infinity
Gauntlet before Christmastime so all you
have to do to enter for your chance to
win is subscribe to my channel like the
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
it's been a crazy day an awesome day
thank you for all the support that
you've given me thank you for watching
all of my videos as always Wolf Wolf
[Music]